salivar es tan fácil como esto
una de las pequeñas cosas que nos da más
placer en la vida es el sabor y cuando
este se encuentra bien almacenado
suceden cosas tan interesantes como
salivar de solamente pero una imagen
ahora estas sensaciones se encuentran
relacionadas experiencias pasadas las
cuales se encuentran almacenadas en
nuestro centro de integración sensorial
la clave de todo esto es de qué manera
almacenamos estos sabores para poder
acceder a ellos de manera más rápida y
sencilla
por ejemplo
ella es la señora juanita
ok entraremos a la biblioteca sensorial
de la señora juanita y veremos qué es lo
que tiene almacenado de ella por el
sabor a naranja
ok todos sabemos que este no es el
verdadero sabor a naranja
el limón y la naranja son de nuestras
sensaciones asociadas sabor más
recordadas de nuestra infancia a nivel
cultural la naranja a diferencia de lo
sucedido con el limón
por su forma y más aún por su color son
herramientas publicitarias muy potentes
ella inducen sentimientos de felicidad y
también inducen activación mental
hoy señora juanita veremos de qué manera
usted almacenó esta información y cómo
podemos hacer que nuestra biblioteca
sensorial sea más fiable y precisa
en nuestra cabeza existen distintos
puntos sensoriales nos vamos a enfocar
de gran medida en lo más sencillo que va
a ser la nariz la boca y lo que las
conectan
en nuestra boca está la lengua la cual
posee las glándulas salivales y también
las papilas gustativas las papilas
gustativas serán las encargadas de tomar
la información sensorial y enviarla a
nuestro cerebro quizás más de algunos ha
visto esta imagen sobre el mapa
sensorial de la lengua
estas imágenes son una representación
artística de la ubicación de las papilas
gustativas en la lengua
no quiere decir que estas papilas
solamente sientan ese gusto en
particular en esa zona en particular
nuestra nariz será la encargada de tomar
los aromas y llevarlo a nuestro punto
sensorial olfativo el cual se encuentra
ubicado de manera muy interesante en la
mitad del trayecto entre la nariz y la
boca
richard axel y linda book ambos premios
nobel de medicina en el año 2004
estuvieron de que el cerebro puede
almacenar hasta 10 mil aromas distintos
pero solamente 200 colores y que nuestra
memoria olfativa puede llegar a durar 10
años en cambio nuestra memoria visual
solamente 3
como tostador de café me fue imposible
no cuestionarme la formación de
conceptos sensoriales porque existían
café especiales maravillosos con sabores
maravillosos y porque había gente que
los podía sentir y gente que no los
podía sentir
a diario vemos como nuestra cafetería de
la gente cuando recibes un café aplica
azúcar directamente sobre el sin
siquiera probarlo y no estaba hablando
de una cucharadita estamos hablando de
56 de hecho el promedio son 3
cucharaditas por taza que es bastante
alto
hicimos el experimento en otra cafetería
un mes de trabajar sin azúcar aún tengo
amenazas de muerte buenas acciones
pero la mayoría de las personas que
estuvieron en esa época todavía siguen
tomando su café sin azúcar y esto es
porque quieres sentir de manera natural
el dulzor de ese café por el cual tanto
luchamos los tostadores ahora un dato
el cazo no tiene por qué ser amargo
cuando hablamos de sabor no nos
referimos específicamente al gusto nos
referimos a una acción combinada el
gusto más el aroma más la experiencia
nos va a determinar lo que es sabor por
gusto nos referimos a las sensaciones de
dulce salado ácido amargo y el último
viento descubierto humano
para referirnos nuestra capacidad de
aromática es necesario compararla con el
mejor amigo del hombre
el perro el perro que tiene un complejo
sistema de limpieza y una larga cavidad
nasal puede aromatizar a kilómetros de
distancia el ser humano por su parte
tiene una corta cavidad nasal pero
también tiene una corta cavidad
retronasal lo que nos permite aromatizar
al momento que estamos deglutiendo en
nuestra boca
el humano se encuentra preparado mucho
mejor que el perro y otros mamíferos
para aromatizar retronasal mente
y bueno nuestra experiencia no puedes
saber a qué sabe el chocolate sino que
has comido chocolate
ok para dar una nueva oportunidad de
sentir ocuparemos tres de nuestras
sensaciones gustativas más básicas y más
sencillas de recalibrar que va a ser el
dulce de salado y el ácido y lo haremos
a través de un ejercicio práctico que
será muy sencillo ocuparemos tres
pasitos de 200 ml de agua filtrada y
aplicaremos en cada uno 10 gramos de
azúcar 10 gramos de sal y 10 gotas de
limón
ahora lo que haremos será ir probando
cada uno de los pasos e ir nombrando lo
en vuelta
esto es dulce esto es salado y esto es
ácido más tan complicado
ok
pasaremos la siguiente etapa en la cual
prepararemos 9 vasos de 200 ml de agua
filtrada y los iremos marcando por
niveles en la parte inferior de cada
vasito lo que haremos será preparar 5
gramos de azúcar 10 gramos de azúcar y
15 gramos de azúcar y los determinaremos
como dulce uno dulce 2 y dulce 3 y esto
lo haremos sucesivamente con el salado y
con el ácido
lo que lograremos con esto será crear
niveles sensoriales gustaría
ok
no sigue siendo tan complicado ahora
cuál es la parte entretenida de todo
esto desordenar los nueve vasos y volver
a ordenarlo en su forma original
eso ha sido un poco más difícil pero con
esto lograremos obviar el mapa sensorial
de la lengua y enfocarnos en la
totalidad de nuestra boca
aparte crearemos distintos niveles gusta
dios ok
diremos gay estos menos dulces o esto es
más dulce y eso se lo enseñamos a
nuestro cerebro directamente con este
ejercicio en particular
para entregar nuestro aroma será tan
fácil como aromatizar algo antes de
comerlo
y mientras lo estamos comiendo
ok y esto lo haremos una manera muy
sencilla y que ocupada por sommelier a
lo largo de la historia y es tan fácil
como expulsar aire por la nariz mientras
estamos destruyendo nuestra boca con
esto arrastraremos lograse los gases y
lo que daremos nuestro punto sensorial
olfativo
nuestra experiencia estará completa una
vez que la asociamos a todos nuestros
otros sentidos como el visual el tacto y
auditivo pero siempre nuestras
herramientas principales será el
olfativo y el gustativo
es posible alcanzar un mayor nivel de
complejidad claro que sí
de hecho deberíamos poder llegar a re
combinar los pasos de un solo vaso
determinar por ejemplo un dulce uno un
salado dos y un ácido uno porque
queremos lograr este nivel de
complejidad porque no es lo mismo ir a
tu casa y comer una manzana o ir a un
restaurant y comer un risotto de
espárragos el resultado espárragos tiene
mucho más complicidad
ahora la clave de todo esto es de qué
manera almacenamos toda esta información
en nuestra biblioteca sensorial para que
eso sea fiable y precisa y cada vez más
grande
ok así que la próxima vez que ustedes
estén en su casa se comen una fruta o
bien un restaurant almacena esta
información de correcta manera con el
producto aromatizar lo pruebe lo voy a
nairobi la nariz le aseguro que su vida
cambiará gracias
[Aplausos]